wir hören jetzt die Weihnachtsgeschichte
nach weselski was
warum es begab sich sch zu der Zeit dass
ein Gebot von Kaiser Klaus wieselski
ausging dass alle Welt zu Hause bliebe
außer an den höchsten Feiertag also
fuhren Josef und seine schwangere Frau
Maria am Heiligen Abend mit dem
Regionalexpress nach belehem bei
geänderter
Wagenreihung leider wurde der Zug kurz
hinter Nazaret umgeleitet nach zahen w
er dann mit Triebwerkschaden liegen
blieb und so wurde der Sohn Gottes also
auf gleich sieben geboren während Josef
sich in einer endlosen Schlange vor dem
sixchalter anstellte frohes Fest
allerseits